well American television viewers are  finally safe from the creepy porn lawyer  thanks to a pair of indictments in New  York in California for extortion and tax  fraud and probably a lot of other things  but until today America's skies remained  vulnerable to CPL this morning though  federal authorities seized the creepy  porn plane that is a five million dollar  jet that the creepy porn lawyer actually  owned he used it to travel during the  rare moments he was not on CNN with that  only two parts of America are still in  peril Iowa and New Hampshire both of  which exposed to a creepy porn  presidential run let's hope he's called  off those plans